parce que c'est aussi critique que les
internautes qui nous envoient leurs
réactions en direct dans la mauvaise
nouvelle sur twitter c'était un des
sujets les plus commentés
aujourd'hui donc avec le hashtag edouard
philippe mais aussi avec le mot-clé
tokyo paris plus de 30 mille tweets et
sur nos articles on a plus de 3000
commentaire donc effectivement les gens
sont assez choqué énervé en fait ce qui
ce qui les énerve surtout c'est le fait
qu'ils aient dit j'assume
ça c'est quelque chose qui ne passe pas
du tout on a notamment gibus 15 qui nous
disent qu'ils nous dit le confort a bon
dos quand ce sont les autres qui paient
pendant des années j'ai fait les 22
heures de vol entre paris et haïti avec
escale à los angeles si je me suis
accoutumé au confort des avions air
france sans être en classe affaires du
temps du ps il est arrivé que certains
disent ce n'est pas cher c'est l'état
qui paye donc rien ne change
or l'état c'est nous cherchez l'erreur
on à la mouche qui nous dit
théoriquement quand on dit j'assume
on en tire les conclusions mais là non
le fait d'assumer et suffisants c'est
devenu le moyen de défense des
politiques qui lorsqu'ils sont pris en
flagrant délit de mauvaise gestion ou
mauvaises décisions nous abreuve d'un
j'assume avant de passer à un autre
sujet le j'assume n'étant suivies
d'aucun acte réparateur s'est tristement
lamentable donc ça c'est à peu près ce
qui ressort dans les commentaires du
figaro sur twitter pareil on a
énormément de personnes qui critiquent
on a notamment en gérant votre foi qui
nous dit 350000 euros tarif du tokyo
paris et 60 colobes pour edouard
philippe et 60 collaborateurs
quand l'ex premier ministre françois
fillon rentrer seul un week-end dans la
sarthe à 250 km le falcon le falcon de
la république coûtait 27000 euros au
tarif fillon tokyo paris coûterait 10
millions d'euros eric naulleau qui nous
dit tokyo paris pour edouard philippe
à ce prix là ce n'est plus un vol c'est
du vol on à vincent castella qui nous
dit cher edouard philippe
donc là il lui adresse une petite lettre
avec une jolie image que vous pouvez
voir à l'écran
trois cent cinquante mille euros pour
son vol tokyo paris cela représente 25
ans de smic ses 100 ans de course pour
une famille quatre personnes ça fait
aussi sur l'image 350 pile de 10 billets
de 100 euros pour ça pour dire que ça en
fera vivre des gens adorent philippe non
marcelino qui nous dit quand tu apprends
le même jour que les impôts augmenteront
de 4 5 milliards d'euros et que le et
que le premier ministe pardon j'ai eu un
bug lourd un avion a350 1000 euros
pourra plus de confort et gagné 2 euros
sur un tokyo paris les sacrifices
toujours les mêmes et enfin le compte
twitter les répliques qui nous dit enfin
qui rappelle un ancien tweet de thomas
porcher qui disait le même odeur
philippe justifier sa politique de
rigueur en disant je souhaiterais que
les français mesurent l'ampleur de ce
dérapage nous n'avons pas le droit de
faire cela nos enfants et je ne reviens
pas de payer cette note
merci ce qui va lancer des patrons sais
pas qu'est-ce qui a balancé l'info 50 ha
c'est une info afp
après qu'ils aient ballon c'est
intéressant mais j'aimerais juste je
posais une question c'est pourquoi
est-ce-que